so I thought the story went bizarrely
underreported because everything related
to Apple gets extremely over reported
but the Wall Street Journal reported
this week that they've got hundreds of
people working on an electric car that's
right we've got some more info for you
the car project is nicknamed Titan Apple
has a team of several hundred people
working on a minivan style car that can
incorporate apples array of
technological products if the vehicle
moves forward it would put Apple in
competition with the other electric car
makers including Tesla and General
Motors all right we know that Apple has
a [ __ ] ton of money how much money do
they have their valued at over 700
billion dollars and they posted 18
billion in quarterly profits uh
they pretty much run everything and more
efficiently certainly than our
government uh but everything when I
heard about this the first thing that I
thought was out man like I'm big on
Tesla I like the idea of it I like
seeing them pop up
they're gonna kill Tesla aren't they uh
by the way the 700 billion is a metric
shit-ton of money okay that's a lot of
money that is in my notes here yeah
metric [ __ ] um like that I'm I
originally I thought I felt bad like
Tesla's doing it yeah and now Apple just
gonna come in and I don't know I don't
know I don't know if there be a beat I
don't know I do you know they got a big
head start yeah you know i and tesla
already has a brand name out there the
people like other people gonna want you
know cars are your phone is
instinctively this is gonna this is me
talking marketing so ignore everything
okay well your phone is supposed to be
geeky yet you acknowledge that it's
geeky right from the start it's the way
cool people are like others my tech
thing right cars aren't geeky cars are
cool they're designing a minivan
Tesla's are cool I don't think Tesla's
threatened by an Apple minivan so the
minivan part of it I do think is weird
but generally Apple stuff is in thought
of as geeky it's thought of as cool
right but the minutes the minivan part
it's still geeky it's cool geeky but
your car is not cool geeky a car isn't
is cool and yeah guys who drive Tesla's
care about cars what well i know that
what i read you didn't have this up
there but if you if you spin out and go
sideways you get your window in
landscape you Apple hey you see what he
did there Jimmy ah technological choice
Apple minivan yeah that's what they're
building the middle
I don't know why they're starting with
the minivan I guess that seems a little
busy you know what actually I like I was
once given a minivan at a rental because
they're out of whatever it's fun yeah
and I enjoyed it and it was it's much
much much easier for kidnapping -
perfecto
Jimmy Dore driving around in any way
less scary true happen it was the first
time I was ever recognized I had my
first half-hour special urges aired yeah
and I go was in Virginia Beach and I go
to get the rental car and the woman
recognized me from my special and she
goes you can have any car you want and I
go thanks I'll take the minivan pull in
the star card
I like the minivan um do you guys think
to me it seems like the good part of
this even though I don't want to see
Tesla go down is that if someone the
electric cars ever gonna really happen
in America it's gonna be Apple right
like it's gonna be Apple or Google right
not going to GM right Ursula well
because it's
it's coming with Tesla it is getting
cheaper but like if someone's gonna
really really deal with the GM could do
it I mean GM's big deal though if they
fail well they have about but but at the
voting right right I did it yeah they
did it so me but if it's gonna but I
mean I'm talking about what really
massive it's gonna mean make a major
dent if 40% of people are gonna be
driving after cries we're gonna actually
reduce our carbon footprint yeah big
companies are presumably going to get
involved in this but this room you know
this if there's room for a zillion uh uh
you know whatever the other kind of cars
what's the normal kind of car powered
attic oh yeah we were I don't know
internal with must Internet's what I was
looking for if the internal combustion
car concern can have thirty five
companies making them I imagine that
dad's not gonna make the only electric
car the people yet Jimmy as my war
correspondent the the war people are
gonna be upset about this right because
the war people want us to be in the
Middle East for oil is less dependent on
oil right there they can't be happy
right they're not know they want the the
March for oil to continue for sure so
it'll continue one way or another I
think certainly it will continue
although I like the idea that that you
know again that apples of that them
getting involved in electric cars I did
doesn't seem like a downside of me yeah
no I know I know it's all good I just
suddenly I drove one Tesla I took one
look test ride with I love it and it was
so cool and it's all digital and all
that I watered a guard last notice how
do you guys feel about Apple in general
because every time we do a story on
Apple
people go crazy because they either got
the total fanboys or the droid people
and everything else that just hate them
and they think that we're all drinking
the kool-aid I was a total fanboy for a
while but now the Steve Jobs is gone I
am NOT and I think there the iPhone is
not on the cutting edge anymore as it
used to be you know there's the androids
have a lot more features than seems like
the iPhone starting to catch up for [ __ ]
which I don't like that feeling I want
to be the guy I want to be with Apple
because they're on the forefront but
that they don't and then they they so
that's how I feel about Apple they keep
[ __ ] up their programs like they did
with iMovie they did with Final Cut they
make it shittier first Ford I don't know
why they do that but anyway because then
the next one's was you better than they
go back to shitty it's like an endless
cycle
oh you have the giant iPhone have you
done five six plus plus uh uh they
screwed up GarageBand I had I did
disband my band yeah
like ah why not tour anymore cuz that
probably wasn't drugs in any other way
knows nobody knows how to use Android
operating system nobody nobody in the
world